well the first place I think we
shouldn't have as many people in
hospitals I think we can do much more
outpatient care and we've already seen
that happen quite wonderfully I mean
cataracts are now like an hour and
outpatient department in your home so I
think we're going to have to do much
more care that keeps people at home and
not enough
better go to work on their diet since
the reason this is the fattest country
in the world is because the baby boomers
they are fat and they are still smoking
at least half of them are and they
aren't saving their money and they're
not exercising despite the notion that
baby boomers are out there physically
exercising they're really not so they've
got a lot to do and they could do it but
it's going to be tough for them to
suddenly change in their lives there now
you know the oldest wants 12,000 more of
them will become 62 today